You've got to accept that not everybody
is going to care about every thing
equally.
And they're sort of different categories
of people always in and around a given
cause or given effort.
I mean there are people who care
passionately about it who have a direct
personal connection.
What we wanted to be sure to do was make
sure that for the motivated person who's
got a target and a goal,
that that what we were engineering was
an incredible toolbox for them to use
all of our best ideas that we've ever
had and even to source from other people
by surfing around in the site,
effective ways of taking their
motivation and their energy and you
know,
leveraging it into really good
productivity in terms of their personal
fundraising.
So on the one hand you want to supply
the motivated person with everything
they need to do a really good job.
The next ring out is people who might
not have a specific connection.
And if the motivated person who cares,
who's reaching out to their own circles
of people,
take people who are already donors to
you and turn them into small fundraisers
for you.
You know,
I mean,
if a person is capable of giving 50
bucks themselves,
but it's really easy for them to reach
out to their family and friends and just
on the strength of personal
relationships,
say,
could I get,
um,
you know,
10 more people to donate 50 bucks,
then they've just multiplied their own
capacity by 10 times.
Anyone who was involved in fundraising
will tell you that that kind of
multiplying effect has huge
ramifications.